what's up everybody welcome back to my
youtube channel richard on data if this
is your first time here my name is
Richard and this is the channel where we
talk about all things data data science
statistics and programming subscribe for
all kinds of content just like this and
hit the notification bell so YouTube
notifies you whenever I upload a video
all right so a while ago I did a video
on how much statistics you need to know
for data science I laid out a lot of
different things and as anyone who's
been in the field for a long time will
tell you statistics is a critically
important component of data science and
there's a lot of concepts you need to be
educated on in order to do effective
applied data science but I think it
raises a pretty natural follow-up
question which is how much pure math do
you need for data science my two-second
answer to that is probably not as much
as you think in fact one of the most
iconic books on machine learning is
introduction to statistical learning
with applications in our and there are
almost no references to calculus in the
whole book so broadly speaking the kind
of math that most people should have
some knowledge of for data science is
going to fall into two major categories
those are calculus and linear algebra so
I'm gonna walk through how math can
manifest inside your data science role
exactly how understanding it can be
useful and then those two topics
calculus and linear algebra individually
as a usual disclaimer all of this is
based on my own experiences anecdotes
from people in my network and some
research I've done so hopefully it
provides you with some helpful food for
thought and who knows maybe even a
little bit of entertainment but before I
do any of that there's one distinction
that should be made and that's the
difference between practical data
science and the theory behind all of it
and I'm gonna have a link in the
description to an article that does a
pretty good job of breaking down that
distinction but in short most people who
do practical data science work are
making use of things which have been
around for a while those could be
statistical methods like t-tests
regression or machine learning
algorithms like K nearest neighbors
random for us neural networks doesn't
matter here's the thing
you're using all those methods because
they've been around for decades or
sometimes even longer than decades and
somebody before you in the past has
discovered that under the right
circumstances these things all work so
that you don't have to for a huge number
of people you don't really need to do
all that much math because especially if
you're using open source software like R
or Python guess what the math has
already implemented like any rule though
that does have exceptions I once knew a
guy who wrote a full-blown logistic
regression model using gradient descent
with full feature and model selection
from scratch using pure c-sharp because
that's the only way we could deploy such
a model to production given our clients
security requirements I don't think I
need to tell you that that requires a
lot of math to do that honestly most
people though are not gonna have to do
stuff like that
but I do think it's fair to say that if
you have none of the mathematical
foundation at all it is going to impair
your ability to interpret what you do
and communicate about it pretty
dramatically take a method like
principal component analysis for example
you may use this as an intermediary so
you pass the principal components into a
predictive model or you may just use it
for exploratory purposes either way
somebody may very well ask you what it
means now if you don't understand
any of the math behind what you've done
it's gonna be way harder to explain your
work to others similarly it'll happen a
lot more often that you run a model or a
method and there's just weird issues
with it like maybe you run a random
forest and the variable importance plot
looks a lot different than you expected
and you're looking at the predictive
performance thinking they should be
doing a lot better than this if you
don't know the underlying math you're
gonna run into problems like that and
it's going to be harder and take a lot
more time to fix them and while I think
for most people implementing full-blown
algorithms from scratch might be a
little bit of a stretch I don't think
it's too stretchy to occasionally have
to come up with your own solutions that
are based on solid mathematical
and statistical principles that's
especially true if you work on any kind
of optimization problem so now that I've
gone through why you might need to know
math and data science let's go through
some of the fundamentals for starters as
far as statistics is concerned you need
to understand probability calculations
and especially conditional probability
but I talked all about that in my how
much statistics do you really need for
data science video there's gonna be a
card for that up above as well as a link
to that in the description as far as
your algebra basics are concerned the
most key expressions are gonna be
logarithms and exponents these show up
in the theory behind tons of different
methods and even in more basic things
like the densities of distributions
Euclidean geometry is important too
because it gives a solid foundation for
tons of different mathematical thinking
but it will also help you understand
algorithms like K nearest neighbor or
k-means clustering then you're also
gonna want to know some basic sequence
and series so data science and
particularly machine learning is full of
summation notation and this stuff even
if you hated learning it as much as I
did in school it is going to come in
handy and be your friend sometimes now
let's talk about calculus so the key
topics from here are limits derivatives
and integrals in particular the real
world is complex and has a lot going on
so all these are going to apply in
multivariate contexts that is functions
with multiple variables computation of
derivatives in particular often requires
use of the product or chain rules so
sorry to those of you who are sitting in
your starter calculus class and you
remember thinking what am I ever going
to need to use this but more generally
with machine learning it is critically
important to understand the concept of
gradient descent and to understand that
you kind of have to understand partial
derivatives as well as the difference
between local and global maxima and
minima then for integrals those are
probably a little bit less important but
it could be helpful to understand
multiple integrals as well as the gamma
and beta functions but overall though it
is highly unlikely that you're gonna
have to do a ton of calculus in your
data science
and for most people I think if you
understand the surface level stuff
you're going to be just fine once again
though I do highly recommend reading all
about gradient descent if you're
unfamiliar with it and understanding all
the math that goes into it it will pay
massive dividends for understanding the
intuition behind machine learning
algorithms as well as explaining them to
other people now we move on to linear
algebra and I gotta admit on this one
this was an early pain point for me back
when I was in college so calculus always
intuitively made sense to me
but I did horribly in my first linear
algebra class sorry to say but if it's
really abstract for you it is a hill
that you have to climb but once you
climb that hill
you'll be extremely glad that you did
linear algebra revolves around vectors
and matrices and you're obviously gonna
need to know how to do matrix algebra so
things like matrix addition matrix
multiplication as well as the transpose
of a matrix solving systems of linear
equations as well as inverting matrices
are going to be useful skills to have
and your tool for that is going to be
Gauss Jordan elimination and then
generally one of the most important
concepts in all of linear algebra is
that of the determinant this is
something that shows up in the theory
behind tons of different algorithms so
knowing how to calculate it as well as
the overall intuition behind it is not
only important but it's gonna give you a
huge aha moment as it comes to
understanding a lot of the different
mathematical ideas in linear algebra in
general concepts like bases the span of
vectors and linear dependence and
independence are important as well now
these things will help you understand
the role that multicollinearity as well
as the assumption of linear independence
plays in regression models then you also
want to understand I ghen values eigen
vectors and singular value decomposition
coming back to principal component
analysis as well as several other
dimensionality reduction techniques the
entire mathematical foundation for them
is based on these concepts so if you
take the time to really learn and
understand these concepts it's really
one of the high
return-on-investment things that you
could do if you're learning math for
data science now naturally this is not a
comprehensive list and in particular if
your role or interests skew more in the
direction of data engineering you may
benefit from knowing some discrete math
similarly if you have a lot of interest
in neural networks and deep learning
knowing some graph theory and real
analysis is gonna serve you well too but
I really do think for most people a lot
of these simply aren't things which
you're going to be making use of every
single day the basics are obviously
gonna help you out but especially in a
field as broad as data science I really
think that's studying some of these
things extensively is going to have some
level of diminishing marginal returns
remember this is a field where things
like communication and domain expertise
and being a solid programmer are all
important skills to have as well and
overall math is wonderful because it's
gonna be around forever if we look back
at the last few decades the programming
languages of choice have shifted around
dramatically but the foundations of math
haven't new methods will come along in
the future - I'm sure but they will all
to some extent rely on the same
mathematical foundation that older
statistical methods did but don't be
intimidated by all the people out there
who make giant listings of all the math
that you need to know for data science
again if you know all the fundamentals
maybe you've taken some classes in the
past and you have some resources to
consult for looking things up I think
you're gonna do just fine so thanks for
watching this video if you enjoyed it
and you'd like to support my work the
most helpful thing that you could do for
me would be to share this video
otherwise at least consider smashing the
like button and then I'll see you all in
the not so distant future until then
Richard on data